chers amis chers ennemis jacquel
maintenant celle sans qui line dardigna
voilà et je ne parle pas de catherine
barma
je parle de madame de fontenay
même le fond tu es un ami patrick
devedjian a porté la dernière fois qu'on
s'est vus à la télévision
je lui ai dit si vous enlevez votre
chapeau je m'habille en blanc la fois
d'après et puis vous avez repris votre
chapeau c'était des cures marines donc
voilà et je me suis donc retrouvé en
blanc pas longtemps la fois d'après
à oui je suis un mec de parole mois
dites moi un truc là par exemple si vous
enlevez votre chapeau qu'est-ce que je
fais là je sais pas grand chose à faire
c'est que je m'habille en blanc vous
connaissez donc benoît delépine
vous connaissez jury vous connaissez
laurent baffie oui elle m'adore non mais
c'est mal on en attend dé moi je suis
pour la paix des ménages
quand je voudrai d'un mec je voudrais en
parler je voudrais qu'on dise les choses
parce que les philippe ménard nous a
donné l'exemple finalement d'une
franchise hors du commun les bêtises
encore il a fait une boulette il a fait
la boulette dans les années 60-70 qui
gardait toujours son chapeau qui
s'appelle daniel girardi le garder parce
qu'il avait un sexe qui poussait sur les
savoirs tenez voilà
c'est une forme d'arythmie c'est une
forme d'art oui c'est madame de fontenay
quant à elle son chapeau et c'est quoi
la france entière une érection et je
sais que chez vous ça vous excite mais
c'est comme ça elle peut pas s'empêcher
alors maison maintenant
maintenant je l'aï dit moi ce qui vous
oppose à la lame de fond rien vous êtes
justement de fontenay je trouve que
c'est qu'en face à l'euribor
particulière de me manifester son
adoration que celles en basse vallée du
bon goût et j'ai une admiration sans
borne battant alors on sait pas
l'intérim ensemble parce que l'incident
est clos je pense que d'orangés d'amis
ça y est oui je suis pas rancunière et
milan en iran
normalement l'image est trop fine à bout
on va pas te laisser tout ça c'est fini
non non non mais c'est l'incident est
clos la danish williams qui boudent
revient football et non début d'érection
et les mariés tous les fidèles à six
morts dont clint rare dit vous la
connaissez bien miss france 92 qui tire
mais préférait d'ailleurs à votre avis
elle a été élue on se calme la fiscalité
du pourquoi pas viser d'abord parce que
les téléspectateurs l'ont élu oui c'est
pour moi qui dis pas parce que l alaska
de ce que vous avez déceler elle a
beaucoup de personnalité elle a du
charisme elle est belle et voilà toutes
les qualités
est ce que la vie critères et les
cheveux parce que le vent l'avait
sèchement préfériez ch mais je peux
quand même oui mais oui j'y pense je
pourrais bien ils fabriquent des
extensions mais tout à fait que tu as
goûté linda c'est vrai que ça lui va
bien mais c'est vrai que quand vous
revoyez entre miss france vous voulez
souvent science souvent on a chacun on a
chacune nous donnons véritable en
reprend mais tu pleures aux ex miss
france on vienne des délégués organise
élection qu'elle a beaucoup changé +92
beau visage
non elles vivent autour de plus en plus
d'assurance et tous et je suis sûr
qu'elle fera une belle carrière la tène
vie vous vous pas ou plus sérieusement
c'est pas un mensonge non pas du tout
ben si thierry de l'affairé c'est que
quand même à la présidence en avait
toujours des dix mois je vous dis assez
d'émotion avec cela vous caresser les
seins en venant ce matin
c'est très content d'apprendre le prénom
tant que ces jeunes viennent parce que
nous on est toujours plus que c'était
madame nancéienne j'aimerais vraiment
que penser de ces belles foyer gaza
belle de fontenay elle s'appelle jeunes
vient de passer le premier bien quant à
celle là thierry lemaître bien rire
personne personne rigole
allez on y va on sortait un lead là
c'était écrit par un de mes frères
voilà alors ça si vous avez un bouquin
c'est suivre oui mais voilà c'est
terrible si vous avez un livre à lire
cette année c'est celui-là accélérer
l'alluré et je les lui et j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir
mais s'ils n'ont rien fait quand vous
tombez en panne d'essence souris au
dessus de l'île et voilà c'est le livre
alors c'est à dire la vérité qui
s'appelle donc geneviève et les siens
qu'un peut agir graphic comme amap c'est
écrit par votre frère donc évidemment il
va pas dire du mal de vous c'est votre
père en russie
quelques problèmes seraient picador fait
très peu oui samir amin on s'entend bien
ouais vous entraider alors c'est la
chronique d'une famille française donc
c'est votre frère qui l'a écrit vous
avez fait la préface on se raconte
l'histoire de votre famille vous dites
que vous allez écrire la suite que vous
allez écrire le deuxième tome est ce que
vous pensez ne pas écrire à écrire après
l'histoire dispense de son le parfum et
vous m'avez imbibé de 2,2 quand il va
rentrer chez lui car taper but c'est pas
croyable alors donc ce livre raconte
votre vie pendant que je parle serge
khalfon si tu veux mettre des photos où
on voit madame madame de fontenay en
barboteuse
et c'est donc vous est l'aîné d'une
famille de dix enfants nés de voila
voila c'est vous la caisse qui c'est
xavier qui t'a donné ces photos j'ai
plus de sens aujourd'hui le petit il a
amené sa soeur linda linda l'ordre à
linda droite oui trick 12 juin droite
xavier mareva georges misse en savoie la
lorelei acquis à gauche et et linda
hardy a et moi cette faute seront servis
en effet la maison parce que c'est chez
vous aussi bien c'est déjà détruite br
derrière lé pas ce qu'est ce qui prouve
qu'on se concevoir d'abord mais j'avais
déjà les cheveux courts donc avant l'été
reste non mais bon alors bon vivant dans
une famille ça c'est l'épaisseur fort
mais c'est pas clair bon boulot à ses
boutons j'aime bien vous êtes génial
quelle bonne idée
alors chaque morceau du massé qui a pas
le chercher chez moi c'est plus la
barbie
bon alors dont vous venez d'une famille
geneviève vous n'avez pas le droit de
parler à table sauf au dessert pouvoir
comme on est éduqué de vous vous voyez
vous vous soignez vos parents c'était ce
n'était pas drôle l'arrivée de martin
est aussi comme n'était pas gentil enfin
mon but est accroché au cou son frère
martin et vincent quand j'allais me
cacher dans le confessionnal pour ne pas
avoir froid
évidemment c'était ça faisait pas bien
ballester le match est-ce que c'est du
martinet de votre enfance que vous
viennent vos penchants sado-maso chant
féminin vous y croyez pas au maroc ouais
j'ai se tirent dessus
alors on l'écouté n'est vraiment là je
luis dois vous étiez une élève pas très
brillante
il faut dire la vérité mais très élégant
dire que déjà qu'il avait commencé à
porter des chapeaux bases élevées dans
l'île à 3 ans j'ai déjà un petit bobo
donc j'allais à la messe avec un chapeau
à l'école avec un chapeau mais oui oui
c'était assez insolite et vos parents
étaient obligés de vous changer d'école
que je sais c'est ouais bah non j'étais
chez les soeurs de la miséricorde est
alors un jour pas marrant d'avoir une
fille qui à l'image une admirable et
mbia be chose mais si vous voulez venir
elle si fort bon alors un jour un je
vous avais marre de tout ça hagondange
longue oui oui c'est tout cet enfant est
un droit de parler à table le martinet
du bien le martinet je peux vous le dire
moi et alors un jeu vous allez mal et
vous allez museler les deux euros
actuellement
non mais c'est vrai alors elle vient que
le seigneur geneviève et après l école
d'esthéticienne et la débarque à paris
tout seul et vous devenez miss élégance
et la vie commence c'est vrai que c'est
mon destin bascule si jamais il a appris
bien j'avais passé à 10 et les ministres
comme l'était avant d'en alors comment
alors maintenant vous allez me dire la
vérité parce que cela m'a demandé
comment vous avez fait vous arrivé à la
gare de l'est avec votre valise
et puis comment entre le moment où vous
arrivez gare de l'est d'hagondange où
l'on grille ou m comment vous
mais un soir avant de rencontrer celui
qui a été mon compagnon pendant 25 ans
louis trop mais voilà je voyageais
j'étais l'esthéticienne g antoine je
voyageais g circulaire en bretagne
notamment je faisais des soins de beauté
et un jour j'ai vu à carnac avait lixon
bis carnac
j'ai dit à mes amis on va aller voir ça
puisqu'à la première fois que
j'entendais parler de lui ce soir là que
j'ai rencontré celui fontenay et là ça a
été on peut je crois qu'on peut le dire
bah non pas tout de suite ma vie m'a dit
ça car je n'avais pas eu mon adresse et
puis après je suis allé à saint cloud et
puis occupé par les voies de bus et va
citer un homme formidable
mais tout a pris je lui dois tout j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration toujours dagnan du
su rester fidèle au delà de l'amour et
parce qu'il faut dire c'est que lui est
mort en regardant et c'est incroyable ça
vient cet album politique voyez à quoi
le soir je pense à face à giscard
mitterrand sérieux cette échéance louis
de fontenelle mary jane diable regarde à
la télé le face-à-face giscard
mitterrand il manger une tartine de
confiture
il meurt 16 mars 80 voilà il a compris
que ça allait mal tourner très bien
qu'on fait que mitterrand allait être et
2500 c'était un homme de gauche avait
mis quoi dans la confiote comme moi
alors je prenais le bia jean supplie dit
ça c'est comme ça j'aime bien ce qu'il
adviendra confiote barre mais j'aime
bien j'aime bien c'est bien je connais
leur chum l'un des maillons forts que
dit m non
non bon enfant c'est un père de famille
exemplaire sophie thalmann m'a dit que
vous étiez très sympa et non pas suite à
un malentendu notre première rencontre
vraiment un malentendu dissipé souviens
toi je me retourne et je suis le seul à
le voir à lui avoir caressé les seins
depuis combien de temps giscard
mitterrand tu veux y retourner
oui mais après après l'émission l'accord
et sans ballon
bon alors faire face à tout le monde en
passant courante
il ya les miss france voilà il y en a eu
beaucoup je vous le dis les choisir
entre entre jouet horse
si jamais les multiples aides avant
d'être présents au coup tu n'as pas de
soi ça serait bien miss corse a très
bien comme ça on est peinard moi je suis
pour miss berry à la tête du rpr
vous avez dit foucault parce
qu'apparemment dit y'a pas le choix
c'est bioware est très bien guillaume
durand auraient péri et pas guillaume
dunand pas du tout pourquoi non pas
geneviève où il voulait pas guillaume
grand nom mais il est beaucoup mieux que
jean comme quoi ça nous prend pourquoi
pas bon mais pourquoi elle avait trop
dit ou pas assez je vais maintenant je
trouve
et ben moi je défends ta gueule pourtant
ben oui alors que durant un jour j'ai
rencontré ma part je pense que c'était
garros m'a même pas dit bonjour j'ai
songé au bio bon alors il est il a eu
peur d une photo de famille quand on se
trouve derrière votre chapeau qu'on
regarde le tennis moi je vais lancer un
appel solennel guillaume je sais que tu
en train d'écrire un livre en ce moment
pour raconter ce qui se passe vraiment
un canal et attention à vous de lépine
et donc guillaume quand vous viendra en
parler j'espère on n'a rien on va vous
réalité je voulais pas/je série conçue
avec ma fille je voulais considéré avec
llodra lounge est rien avec dernier n'a
jamais rien gagné mais j'ai pas j'ai
senti pendant les deux jours où les
médias et les hommes ont déjà montré
qu'ils étaient 2 de v depuis son arrivée
deuil des gens qui ont du talent bon ben
si les arméniens ont plus de talent tu
les veux en tout cas ces raisons il y en
a trois bon mais merci à jean belotti du
livre est ce que j'avais les cia voilà
c'est fait la promo montrer la caméra
frontale
caracol voilà j'aime bien mais les siens
donc par paul newman
chers amis